this week
on brian ross investigates
[Music]
sounding the alarm for america's
firefighters
is a chemical that's been used to
waterproof their turnout gear
posing its own risk to the brave men and
women who are called to go into burning
buildings
there's a strong correlation between the
c8 form of this chemical
and two types of cancer testicular
cancer and kidney cancer
it's the same class of chemicals also
used in fire fighting foam
there's 1.2 million firefighters out
there and nobody's telling them about
this stuff
retired firefighter paul cotter and his
wife diane
now trying to spread the word about the
risk after his diagnosis
with prostate cancer i was pissed
and as a lot of firefighters are in the
same boat that i am
this is a epic
disaster as far as we're concerned we
call it the greatest deception ever
the companies that make the specialized
fabric used in the turnout gear
say they would never do anything to put
firefighters at risk
lion is the world's largest supplier of
firefighter protective clothing
it's a responsibility we take very
seriously but with cancer
now the leading cause of death for
america's firefighters there's growing
concern
at america's firehouses i'm being very
honest with you i was completely blown
away
never in my mind did i think the
protective equipment
that i put on to do my job is what could
possibly be killing my numbers
plus this week's winners and losers in
the media
covering the insurrection in washington
see if you agree
with the editors of mediatek
from the law on crime trial network this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz
and rhonda january is firefighters
cancer awareness month
and we begin with a report about growing
concern by firefighters
in firehouses across the country
cancer is now the leading cause of death
amongst firefighters on the
on the job the statistics are astounding
between 2002 and 2019
66 of firefighters died from cancer in a
list that's kept by the international
association of firefighters
and the ages of those dying from cancer
is getting younger
and rhonda of course it's a clear
concern for firefighters they know about
the risk from
smoke that they breathe in and fumes in
their fighting fires
but tonight we're going to report on
something else the protective gear they
wear
which may bring its own risk to them
an alarm tonight from scientists for
america's firefighters
about a class of chemicals that has been
used for years to waterproof
what is known as their turnout gear it's
added to the turnout gear
to keep them dry when a firefighter is
actively using a hose they get wet if
you are carrying 60 pounds of gear
already
adding 40 extra pounds of water weight
when you get wet is
a real it cuts down the time that a
firefighter can be active on scene
but professor graham peasley at notre
dame university
who's been studying the turnout gear
used by fire departments
across the country says the chemical
used most widely until recently
known by its shorthand c8 presents its
own
risk to firefighters there's a strong
correlation between the c8 form of this
chemical
and two types of cancer testicular
cancer and kidney cancer
it's the same class of chemicals in the
foam used by firefighters to put out
certain kinds of fires
there's 1.2 million firefighters out
there and nobody's telling them about
this stuff so that's the most troubling
aspect to it to me it was the case of a
worcester massachusetts firefighter
paul cotter that helped to spur the
professor's research
i was diagnosed with prostate cancer
in october of 2014
i had treatment
surgery early in 15 and uh
who had to retire from a job
at any point when you were serving as a
fire lieutenant on the force there
did you have any kind of warning that
there was this potential harm
from the turnout gear the chemicals used
to coat it
no none at all none at all
no one ever no one ever thought about
the gears
being dangerous
we wore it shopping we wore it sitting
around in the kitchen
um you know it was our safety net
gear it was only after cotter's cancer
diagnosis
when his wife diane began to do her own
research and contacted the notre dame
professor
that he learned of the potential risk
i was pissed and as a lot of
firefighters
are in the same boat that i am it led
diane to become a champion
in the cause to investigate the use of
the chemicals
in firefighters turnout gear it changed
everything brian
when i tell you it changed everything
believe me
you don't want that cancer diagnosis
i get very emotional speaking about it
because he was
a fireman's firefighter so even now five
years later it's
difficult to talk about this is
a epic disaster
as far as we're concerned we call it the
greatest deception ever
no direct link has been proven between
the chemicals used on the turnout gear
and any specific firefighters cancer
diagnosis
but a growing number of firefighters are
demanding answers
my name is jason burns i'm a firefighter
at the fall river fire department
do you see a connection between the
cancer and the chemicals used
in both foam to fight fires and in your
turnout gear
we do cancer's always been prevalent in
our job but now we're starting to focus
on
the materials that's in our gear is that
a surprise to you that that would be an
issue that would be a risk
i'm being very honest with you i was
completely blown away never
in my mind did i think the protective
equipment that i put on to do
my job is what could possibly be killing
my members
and have you seen a rash of cancer
deaths in uh
your department we've we've
experienced not only cancer deaths in
and
the number of of cancer diagnosis have
increased
what is happening which is also very
concerning is the number of
diagnoses are going up but we're also
getting firefighters who are getting
diagnosed at a younger age
which is which is very concerning burns
says two of his firefighters in their
30s
died after cancer diagnoses it's it's
heartbreaking i'm joking i'm just
thinking about it talking to you right
now
one of the guys that i buried was a
childhood friend our kids are around the
same age
um it's it's very difficult you know it
hurts
studies show that the leading cause of
death for firefighters
is cancer with a greatly elevated rate
of cancer than the national average
the presence of the chemicals has
triggered lawsuits around the country
initially over its use in firefighting
foam
and now over its use in firefighters
turnout gear
knowing what we know now uh
number one it shouldn't be in the gear
in the first place and number two we
should have been warned um
and there should have been alternatives
made available to us
there are lots of hazards you face as a
firefighter could it not be that just
the toxic
smoke is the cause of this problem
it's possible uh but here's a known
carcinogen in front of us
that we can do something about
a few seconds can make or break a card
it can save your life in a video
commercial posted online
one of the manufacturers of the gear
dupont talks about the virtues of the
material used
made in conjunction with another company
life
lion is the world's largest supplier of
firefighter protective clothing
it's a responsibility we take very
seriously the video makes no mention of
any health issues
and the companies say the gear is safe
that there are only
insignificant trace amounts of the
chemical in the gear
they say they've now stopped using the
c8 formulation
switching to a different formulation
which professor peasley believes
is something called c6 they they were
all c8 up until about five years ago
uh and so now they've migrated away from
that and they're using uh
ostensibly c6 but no industrial process
is perfect
and the professor is concerned there is
still a lot of older turnout gear being
used
with the c8 and that not enough is still
known about the risks of c6
it's not clear to me that the c6
chemistry is
any better than the c8 chemistry it may
end up being well-being
uh we'll find out in 10 years that's a
regrettable substitution but most of
firefighters aren't aware that they
shouldn't be handling this stuff
uh and that's that's the issue you need
to be washing your hands after you touch
it
you know this is this is dangerous um
stuff that you're wearing and we can't
just look blindly at it
and say the new replacement chemicals
are fine
we need to hear from the independent
scientists
and um you know we need safety alerts
right now
in fact those safety alerts are
literally five years
too late we have wasted a lot of time
and so for uh really uh the more than a
million firefighters in this country and
many more around the world
this you think is a real and present
danger absolutely
a real present danger
next we'll talk with a lawyer who has
helped reveal the widespread use of
these chemicals in the blood of almost
every american his name is rob balot and
hollywood has already made him a hero
in the movie dark waters he's played by
the actor mark ruffalo
in a moment we'll talk with the real rob
balot
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
we're joined now by rob balot the lawyer
who first helped to
sound the alarm about the widely used
chemicals that have a potential risk of
cancer including for firefighters
from their turnock gear which is
waterproof by the chemicals
mr balot's efforts were chronicled by
hollywood
in the movie dark waters where he's
played by the actor
mark ruffalo later both the actor and
rob balot testified before congress
about the issue
i've not only discovered that these
toxic chemicals were building up in our
blood
he also sounded the alarm sharing what
he found with the epa
and also rob secured the funding through
a legal settlement
with dupont to undertake the biggest
human health
study of toxic chemicals ever
rob balot thank you so much for joining
us this concern about firefighters is
just one of a number of concerns about
people who have been exposed to this
chemical how widespread is the exposure
well thanks for having me unfortunately
we're talking about
global exposure and these chemicals
are now in the blood of virtually every
person
on the planet and virtually almost every
living thing
on the planet from people to polar bears
to polar bears really that far to the
arctic circle and beyond
these particular chemicals have an
ability to
once they're released out into the
environment not only do they
have this unique chemical structure of
carbons attached to fluorine
that make it very difficult for them to
break down in the environment
and that's why you hear them referred to
as forever chemicals now because once
they're out in our environment
they can stay there virtually forever
but they also have this unusual ability
to get into us to get into living things
including people
where they can stick in our blood and
build up to higher and higher levels
over time
that's why there's so much concern about
any potential paths of exposure to these
chemicals you know we first found out
about these chemicals some 20 years ago
by being in the drinking water and
there's been a lot of focus on exposure
to drinking water but we're just
now starting to raise awareness of the
other pathways
that people can be exposed such as with
firefighters
being exposed to these chemicals not
only possibly in their drinking water or
food or products but
firefighting foam and as we're hearing
now the potential to
have been used in the coatings on
turnout gear
as you know the industry says the
amounts of the chemicals used in the
turnout gear are so small
just trace amounts that they really
don't pose any kind of risk
to firefighters what do you say to that
well you have to look at the nature of
the chemicals that we're talking about
here
and the the it's the it's this ability
to
to even the smallest amount that we're
exposed to
has the ability to get in us and stay
there and build up to higher and higher
levels
so it's not so much uh you shouldn't
necessarily be focused on how much is
there right now
in this particular exposure but how much
have i been exposed to
over time because all of that is
building up and can build up in our
blood
over time so if you're exposed to even
the tiniest amounts
something that somebody may call trace
amounts
over and over many years or over
continuous exposures
wearing something every day that might
expose you to this
over many many years those levels can
build up in our blood
to to levels where scientists and
regulators all over the
all over the globe at this point are
expressing
serious concerns about those exposures
rob a question for you from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
as you've described this family of
chemicals is in a lot of products
uh around us and most recently now it's
been found in turnout
gear and what advice would you have for
firefighters who are using turnout gear
particularly what they call the legacy
gear gear that was made years ago
before any of these hazards were
discovered
well i think one of the things obviously
that's most important
is knowledge and awareness to at least
first become aware that this potential
for exposure is out there
and make sure that i don't think anybody
is saying that you shouldn't wear your
turnout gear i mean that's
absolutely critical but be a be advised
about when to wear it and make sure that
you're not exposing yourself
unnecessarily
wearing it outside the job or in other
circumstances where
where you don't necessarily have to have
that that material on
to you know for purposes of the job
really
once you become aware that this
potential for exposure is there
you at least have the ability to start
minimizing that and making sure that
you're
only using it when you absolutely need
to
so rob finally let me ask you has the
industry accepted any of the findings
are they making any
uh changes in their production in the
way they manufacture these chemicals or
is there another way to waterproof this
gear
yeah what we've seen is as information
finally started to come out to the
public to the scientific world to the
regulatory world over the last
uh oh gosh man several years as this
information finally came out about the
toxicity of pfoa
and related chemical like pfos that are
part of this forever chemical
phos family what we saw happen was the
manufacturers
of those pfoa pfos the c8s
that are the the ones of concern that
have been used in these
fabric treatments in many years past
manufacturers started switching away
and started moving to different
chemicals
but unfortunately some of the chemicals
they moved to
were just slightly different as you
heard dr peaslee mentioned
instead of a c8 maybe they knocked a
couple of carbons off and called it c6
or c4s
and unfortunately that stuff is now
being put out into the market
being used in these products and the
scientific world
is still investigating to what extent
these chemicals really
are all that much safer you know will
they in fact
not build up in our blood to the same
degree that the other ones do
and unfortunately some of the toxicology
data that's coming in on
animal studies that are starting to be
done are showing some of the same toxic
effects
of the old chemicals so there's this
real concern as you heard about
regrettable substitutions
you know are we simply moving from one
problem to another
when there are a lot of folks that are
out saying we ought to be moving away
from this whole
pfas chemistry into alternative
chemicals
for coatings of these types of materials
so there are a lot of folks looking into
this now
and one of the things i'm really trying
to do is make sure that the science
is done by independent scientists to
confirm
what this big group and class of
chemicals are actually doing to us
the companies shouldn't be allowed to
sit back say
you can't prove that this is causing
harm yet not do the studies that are
necessary to tell people
to tell us exactly what these chemicals
are doing to us
when they all get in us in mix and get
into our blood
that's something i'm trying to pursue
right now through a lawsuit we filed a
couple years ago and
actually our lead plaintiff is an ohio
firefighter
where we're trying to not get money but
get
studies in confirmations conformational
studies done
of what these chemicals can do to people
who are exposed including firefighters
who might be exposed through
their equipment or through the
firefighting foams
all right rob a lot thank you so much we
look forward to seeing more about the
studies
and the continuing case and cause for
concern thanks so very much
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
covering the insurrection in washington
see if you agree with the editors of
mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of media we're
joined by aidan mclaughlin who is the
editor-in-chief of mediaite
which like the law and crime trial
network is part of the dan abrams media
empire
and aiden the big winners were at cnn
with a
shakeup of assignments what happened
that's right so both cnn and fox news
announced their new
programming slates uh for the new
administration uh this typically happens
you know around when we have a
transition of power
from one president to another uh the big
win
at cnn uh in their shake up was jake
tapper he's the anchor of uh the day
show
the lead um which is on at 4pm and uh he
got given an extra hour
uh daily uh in the 5 p.m hour shortening
wolf blitzer
who was uh on after him on cnn um so now
jake tapper's hosting
two hours a day during the weekdays uh
which is a serious vote of confidence
from
uh the bosses at cnn uh and reflects the
the role that jake tapper has taken at
the network
as sort of the washington uh anchor that
covers all the big news events in
washington
he certainly has become the lead anchor
and of course in uh television like that
air time is everything
so who were the winners or losers at fox
right so fox news had their own uh
shake-up of their programming
um theirs was really remarkable they
basically put a new opinion hour
uh at 7 00 p.m on the network which is
sort of just before their big opinion
primetime slate uh they haven't
announced a
a host for that hour of television um
but the
the person who occupied that hour was
martha mccallum who actually had a news
show
the story at 7 pm now to make way for
that new opinion show
martha mccallum has been knocked back to
3 p.m uh which was shepard smith's old
spot
now fox's is adamant that this is not an
emotion for martha mccallum they're just
saying that you know 3 p.m is a news
hour and 7 p.m was an opinion one
so they're just changing her around a
little bit but it's certainly a less
less coveted real estate uh at fox news
um that also means that bill hemmer who
had 3pm and replaced
shepard smith has been moved back to
mornings he's now anchoring
from 9 to 11 at fox news
all right and they all scramble to
figure out how to cover the new
president president biden
to be sworn in next week aidan
mclaughlin thank you so much for joining
us and thanks to all of you for watching
and thanks to our great team along crime
for getting us on the air
and off the air have a good evening
[Music]
you